a common active learning technique that
people often use or often maybe the
first technique that they use is
personal response systems so that's an
opportunity for students to to respond
to a question and that can be anything
it's usually a multiple-choice question
but it doesn't have to be and it can be
anything from a show of hands who thinks
the answer is a who thinks the answers
be who thinks the answers see to
dedicated devices and applications that
allow students to respond to questions
so there's pros and cons for each of the
different techniques but the essence of
all the techniques is that students are
given an opportunity to think about the
answer that they would the answer they
think is correct and and then respond to
that and there is evidence to show
research that shows that when students
make a claim that are when they're asked
to make a public response a public claim
as to what they think the correct answer
is that makes them more committed to the
answer and then they're more likely to
remember or to even notice if their
answer is incorrect it Prime's the
student for learning and that's the
biggest advantage for any of the purpose
personal response systems the
disadvantage with having students raise
their hands is that in a big lecture
hall it can be hard to count right it
can be hard to say okay how many people
raise their hands when I said a how many
when I said B etc so that that can take
up time and it can be pretty inaccurate
the other thing that people do sometimes
is they'll use a like just a sheet of
paper they'll put on letters and then
the students can fold the paper up and
depending on how they want to vote they
just hold it up so that so they you know
only really only you can see it point of
fact is other students can kind of tell
what the other students answered and and
if I know that a friend of mine always
gets the answer right then I might just
look and see what he or she said and
then and then answer the same so it
might not give us a real accurate
accurate measurement of what every
student thinks the other problem with
that is it could this can be hard to
read in a big lecture hall sort of the
first kind of digital or electronic
personal spot response systems where
these dedicated clickers is what they're
called and students literally they they
log in to the system they turn their
devices on and you ask a question and
then you just the students respond ABCD
using the touch pad some some clickers
let students actually type answers so
open response they can actually type a
word or a number a set of numbers so
that can give you a little bit more
flexibility and then the software on the
instructors computer will create a
histogram of responses so you know right
away they're just the distribution of
responses if you have more than 70% of
the students get the question right you
probably just want to state the correct
answer and move on you can also say if
you didn't get it right here's some
extra resources or go to the TA office
hours or whatever but in but in general
if more than 70% of the students get it
right you can you can move on one thing
I like to do is if I really have a
resounding say 75 percent can get it
right I like to ask a follow-up clicker
question that says how confident were
you in your answer because sometimes
students will just guess and if you give
them the opportunity to say yeah I got
it right but I don't really know why
that that might be the situation
sometimes that a lot of people get it
right but not that many people know
what's going on so you want to know that
too if between 30 and 70 get it correct
then I like to move into the pair share
so I like to say okay let's divide up
looks like we have a pretty good split
of answers so let's talk to talk to each
other and peer we can do some peer peer
learning where peers can try to argue
their point to their their whoever's
sitting next to them and then I ask them
to vote again now when things are
working well people actually converge to
the correct answer and and generally
speaking I think it was Eric Mazur has a
has a preliminary research study that
shows that when you put two students
with the incorrect answer together they
actually tend to converge to the correct
answer because they argue each other out
of their respective wrong answers so
that can be pretty effective you do have
to have a pretty good distribution of
correct answers for that to work I have
to students have the same incorrect
answer generally speaking they stay
embedded with the incorrect answer if
less than 30% of students get the
correct answer you probably just want to
stop and reformulate your explanation
and really go over everything again
because that's really not a lot of
people that know what's going on so
that's the general ballpark for how to
proceed with the clicker questions in
between the pieces of paper and the
clickers are some newer technologies
newer applications one is there's a few
applications for web enabled devices
like Socrative which is a software that
you can download the in the instructor
downloads it and then students log into
a room using their web enabled device so
they log in and then no one has to buy
anything extra but you are assuming that
every student has a web enabled device
and you are saying you're happy if they
take them out in your class which may
not be true for everyone so that's the
issue with that access and also whether
you want the smart phones out an
application that I think is a really
great compromise is something called
plickers
with a PP li ckers and with that the
instructor downloads an application on
his or her smartphone or web enabled
device when it has to be a device with a
camera and the students and then you
down and then the instructor downloads
these PDFs which are just pieces of
paper with with them with these patterns
on them they're all different and I
believe you get 40 patterns for for free
and they're reusable and so each one is
unique and you give them to the students
and students then vote a B C or D
there's four sides to the shape and four
letters a B C D and if they think the
answer is a they hold it with the a at
the top they think it's B they hold it
with the B at the top et cetera and you
can use your web enabled device and you
scan the crowd and that with the
software and that
actually picks up the responses and
creates a histogram so I think that's a
really nice compromise because it gives
you the histogram it has student and on
it anonymity and students don't need
anything but the piece of paper that you
gave them and you can actually reuse the
piece of paper we printed sets on
cardstock which are pretty durable and
we can use them over and over again so
there's no there's the students don't
need any extra technology for educators
that are thinking about using some kind
of personal response system for their
for their students there's a couple
different levels of how far in to get
and how fast the first step would be to
construct some really good thoughtful
questions that students can answer in a
multiple-choice way that would let you
use the clickers or a show of hands or
any of the other methods it is important
to construct the clicker questions in a
way that our that students know they're
really meaningful that you're not just
asking kind of silly questions you want
to ask some questions that that are a
bit rich and that also lend themselves
as I said to if students you know if a
decent number don't get them right that
lend themselves to that pure pure pure
interaction this sort of debate with
each other so you don't you want to
think carefully about your learning
outcomes what you want students to know
or be able to do by the end of the class
and you want to construct questions that
help them get there and test whether
they're there or not so you might use
one or two or three questions in a class
and and that might be it that might be
all you do but you do want to make sure
you construct the questions thoughtfully
the next sort of the if you want to go
further in is to think about what it is
really think critically about your
learning outcome what do I want students
to get out of this class this particular
class and then construct a series of
clicker questions that really help
students understand whether they get it
or not help them argue their point with
others or encourage them to argue their
their opinion or point with others and
then ultimately come to a realization or
come to
or come to attain the learning outcomes
really by engagement with the clicker
questions and by engagement in a
subsequent discussion so where the
clicker questions are really the core of
your of your of your class and and the
learning happens sort of threaded among
those questions